bonjour à vous j'avais des dizaines de
sujets qui me passionnait dont j'avais
envie de vous parler ça a été vraiment
une vraie question pour moi de choisir
alors du coup je me suis posé une
question c'était la dernière occasion
que j'avais exprimé auprès de personnes
que j'aime c'était la dernière
le dernier jour de ma vie de quoi
j'aimerais parler aujourd'hui j'aimerais
vous parler du pouvoir des rêves et
trois découvertes que j'ai fait à ce
sujet la première question que
j'aimerais savoir c'est qui ici un rêve
lever la main j'ai toujours peur que les
personnes qui de rêve super alors un bon
moyen de vous en parler
je voudrais vous parler de cette arme
finalement cet arbre il est petit il est
fragile comme on vient de le voir et
pourrait se passer plein de choses il
pourrait mourir d'une sécheresse
pourrait manquer d'eau vous pourrez
l'écraser il pourrait tomber malade
finalement si je m'en occupe je pourrais
même est joué
du coup ça soulève une question pourquoi
sur l'occuper alors finalement nous ne
sommes pas certains qu'il va devenir un
grand art pour répondre à cette question
j'aimerais vous raconter une histoire
l'histoire de quelqu'un que j'ai bien
connu imaginez une personne mal dans sa
peau si vide qui n'était pas à l'aise
avec les autres par les avec la vie par
les avec lui même ils passent de longues
heures à jouer des jeux vidéo pour fuir
la vie furent ses rêves fuir ses projets
on connaît tous ce genre de moment où il
ya une petite voix l'intérieur de nous
qui nous murmure de faire quelque chose
pour nos rêves on a tous développé notre
propre stratégie pour pas entendre cette
voix parmi les plus répandues que j'ai
trouvé j'ai trouvé le chocolat et la
tartiflette
alors je sais pas vous mais quand j'ai
le ventre rempli d'une bonne grosse
tartiflette je suis je suis assis sur
mon canapé
là c'est clair j'entends pas la petite
voix qui dit tu devrais faire ça pour
tes rêves leur pouvoir revenir à cette
personne
secrètement il avait des rêves il rêvait
d'être plus confiants il rêvait d'être
plus à l'aise il rêvait de pouvoir se
créer du vestibule ans et une vie sur
mesure
son problème c'était pas de ne pas
savoir comment faire son problème c'est
qu'il se disait à quoi bon faire quoi
que ce soit alors que je suis
sur ces marchés il avait tellement peur
de l'échec tellement peur de ne pas
réussir qu'il le faisait rien et puis un
jour il tombe sur une vidéo une vidéo de
martin luther king
le fameux discours vous devez connaître
aya n'dri cette vidéo lui mais des
frissons dans le dos et il fait prendre
une décision la décision se créer une
vie extraordinaire
à ses yeux en tout cas et il fait une
première découverte et pour vous
expliquer cette première découverte
devrait en revenir à cet arbre
effectivement pourquoi se sont occupés
de cet arbre alors que nous sommes pas
certains qu'il va devenir un jour un
grand h
c'est vrai nous avons aucune garantie
j'en ai aucune aucune garantie que je
vais réussir à m'occuper de cet arbre en
revanche je peux vous garantir un truc
c'est que si j'ai craint boys cet arbre
moi même là je peux vous garantir qu'il
sera jamais un grand arbre bon je vous
rassure c'est un super fille céline en
plastique cela et c'était ma première
découverte sur des crasses nous mêmes
nos rêves il n'y a plus aucune chance
oui nous sommes pas certains ni d'y
arriver
l'idée chou est alors pourquoi pas
tenter le jeune dont je vous parlais la
personne dont je vous parlais c'était
moi je passais mon temps à m'écraser je
passais mon temps à m'insulter je
passais mon temps à écraser mes rêves
sous prétexte que c'était pas possible
sous prétexte que les autres me disais
que c'était pas possible sous prétexte
que les statistiques se disait que ce
n'est pas possible
et puis un jour j'ai vraiment compris
que peut-être que c'était pas possible
mais de toute façon si j'écrase même le
rêve là c'est sûr que s'impose pour
mieux vous expliquer cette idée vous
raconter l'histoire de cinq personnes
que vous connaissez serment certainement
il a été viré de son équipe de basket
considéré comme trop mauvais michael
jordan il a été refusé trois fois dans
une école de cinéma steven spielberg
il est viré de son journal pour manque
d'imagination
walt disney 30 maisons d'édition vont
lui dire que son livre n'a pas les
ingrédients d'un bon livre
jk rowling harry potter ses professeurs
de chant pour lui dire qu'il n'a ni la
taille ni la voix ni la culture évolue
des conseillers de chanter charles
aznavour mon propos là dedans
il n'est pas de dire que si tu y crois
tu vas y arriver bien entendu les cinq
personnes que vous hésitez avait plein
d'autres choses pour réussir vous
propose celle inverse c'est que s'ils
avaient écrasé eux mêmes leurs rêves
si la décrue les gens à qui leur ont dit
que c'était impossible s'ils s'étaient
crus le même quand il s'était dit que
c'est impossible on ne connaîtrait même
pas leur nom cette idée chez moi elle a
vraiment déclenché une frénésie une
envie de passer à l'action lors du coup
j'ai inversé la question de pourquoi
agir alors que je ne suis pas sûr d'y
arriver à pourquoi pas agir mais je ne
suis pas sûr d'échouer passons d'un
monde où il faut que ce soit 100%
possible pour tenter à un monde qui
c'est juste un peu possible je vais
tenter
j'ai à la base un parcours qui aiment
plutôt scientifique et donc j'aime ce
qui est mesurable
j'ai demandé à plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes de participer à
l'expérience et 4000 ont joué le jeu
alors on leur demande de penser un rêve
un projet important pour eux et pour
lequel ils ont parfois des doutes pour
lesquels ils se disent parfois ça c'est
impossible
le test est simple il dure deux minutes
et ses cinq questions on leur demande
d'évaluer leur niveau de confiance sur
10 et la moyenne alors je serais si vous
arrivez à lire la moyenne elle est de 6
sur 10 de confiance juste en posant
cette question là ensuite on leur
demande s'ils soit 100% sûr que c'est
impossible et 92% des 4000 personnes
vont répondre que non ils sont pas sûrs
que c'est impossible
en quoi la question toute simple est
intéressant c'est qu'on oriente leur
esprit de l'impossible à ce qui est
possible et cette question toute simple
ou j'oriente mon esprit va faire passer
leur niveau de confiance
on leur demande à nouveau de s'évaluer à
6,9 à gauche c'était le tableau initial
à droite c'est le tableau juste après
cette question soit 16 95% croissance de
confiance en plus puis ensuite
on leur demande de penser à quelque
chose qu'ils ont réussi qui leur
semblait impossible
là c'est encore plus intéressant parce
qu'ils vont aller chercher des
références du passé qui va renforcer la
croyance que l'impossible peut devenir
possible une fois qu'ils y pensent
on leur demande à nouveau de s'évaluer
sur dix dans leur niveau de confiance
d'atteindre le projet où le rêve qui
leur semblait impossible et il passe à
7,5 sur 10 jours apple c'était tout vous
rappelle c'était 6 au début soit 27 % de
croissance par rapport à la confiance
initial et enfin pour là on l'a fait
l'intérieur pour aller à l'extérieur on
va leur demander de penser à une
personne qui les inspirent qui a réussi
quelque chose qui lui semblait
impossible
ils prennent le temps de le retrouver il
prenne le temps d'y penser et je vais
leur demander à nouveau votre niveau de
confiance sur dix il est combien on
voyait que même à l'extérieur de vous
des gens peuvent penser que quelque
chose est impossible et il peut devenir
possible et je leur demande à nouveau de
ses volumes sur dix est en l'espace de
cinq minutes ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est qu'ils sont passés en
moyenne de 6 sur 10 de confiance à 7,9
de confiance soit 33 9% de croissance
encore une fois mon propos n'est pas de
dire je suis tassé cinq minutes il va
33% de plus qui vont réussir leurs rêves
vous propose les dire que si je passe
mon temps comme je le faisais moi à
focaliser sur ce qui est pas possible à
focaliser sur ce que je vais pas réussir
là c'est sûr je peux pas je vais pas y
arriver
al'inverse et si je devais refaire
l'expérience je rajouterais une question
c'est votre niveau sur dix de désir de
passer à l'action après le test parce
que c'est ça qui fait la différence à
chaque fois que j'ai pu faire
l'expérience en réel là c'était paraît
elle s'était aussitôt relayée sur
internet j'ai pu observer que le niveau
d'énergie de la personne mentait et son
désir derrière de passer à l'action est
monté lorsque je trouve vraiment
intéressant là dedans
imaginez imaginez nous vous et moi tous
les jours nous rappeler des choses qu'on
a réussi des choses impossibles qui sont
devenues possibles
est ce que ça pourrait transformer notre
rapport à ce qui nous semble impossible
cette découverte est cette première
découverte
elle a déclenché chez moi une frénésie à
l'action je vous rappelle j'étais mal
dans ma peau timide des pensées de
suicide
et là d'un coup je passe d'un tunnel
sans lumière avec l'idée qui a d'un coup
de l'espoir
alors je fais tout ce qui est en mon
pouvoir en disant qu'un jour j'y
arriverai être je mets à parler à des
dizaines des centaines d'inconnus dans
la rue je lève la main en cours le plus
possible alors que je parlais jamais je
m'inscris au théâtre je m'inscris au
rugby or pour le rugby ya plein de
personnes qui me disent ce n'est pas
flagrant quand tu vois c'était hier de
temps et puis en 2010 fait la liste de
tous les rêves des plus simples aux plus
fous j'aimerais réaliser
parmi ceux là y'avait bordeaux et
neurosciences il y avait le fait de
prendre un porte-voix pour véhiculer
plus ou moins le même message dans le
métro j'ai laissé un paquet de métro
passé avant d'oser mais j'ai pu le faire
et puis avait créé ma chaîne youtube
vous laisse imaginer un timide mal dans
sa peau j'ai déjà mis six mois avant
d'oser appuyé sur le bouton publier je
publie la vidéo est là j'attendais
patiemment mon premier commentaire
youtube vous avez sous la vidéo défaut
la vie généreuse il faut la vie et
généreuse mon premier commentaire
c'était tu ne mérite pas de vivre
donc j'ai bien un petit peu de temps à
transformer ça et puis du coup de suite
à ça j'ai créé mon entreprise j'ai
décidé d'animer des conférences tous les
jours pour vraiment devenir un meilleur
conférencier je me suis lancé le défi le
défi fou de partir aux etats-unis avec
un anglais plus que très très moyen sans
connaître ces personnes là pour
interviewer les gens qui m'inspirent est
alors j'ai très peu de temps je bute
chef des conférences qui dure deux jours
2 heures de plus que 18 minutes au lieu
peu de temps
récemment je regardais les vidéos c'est
intéressant parce que je vois dans le
regard des américains qu'ils comprennent
que je les comprends pas je vois même
que quand il raconte une blague je vois
dans leurs yeux qu'ils sont en train de
se dire est ce que vraiment il a compris
que c'est une blague d'ailleurs après ce
que j'ai fermé près de 200 interviews
après une dizaine d'interviews j'avais
même développé une technique pour rire
dans le doute quand j'étais pas sûr que
c'était vraiment une blague ou pas alors
pourquoi je passais autant l'action
parce que j'avais un peu ce fantasme que
c'est en réalisant tous ses rêves que
j'arriverai finalement être heureux et
puis j'ai fait une deuxième découverte
qui était encore plus importante pour
moi que la première qu'est ce qui était
le plus important est le plus fort dans
le fait avoir
toutes ces actions c'était pas ce que
j'avais réalisé au final mais c'était
l'homme que j'ai devenu l'homme que
j'étais devenu combien ça vaut l'homme
qu'on est devenu l'homme que vous êtes
la femme que vous êtes devenu
aujourd'hui est donc le but d'un rêve
n'est même pas d'être réalisé mais de
nous réaliser
on peut nous enlever notre argent notre
métier c'est qu'on possède
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour peut
pas nous enlever la personne qu'on aime
et là c'est complètement différent tout
à l'heure j'agissais vers mes rêves pour
un jour peut-être être heureux mais
l'aja gibert mes rêves parce que mes
rêves et ils me rendent vivent là dès
maintenant il donne de l'énergie
del un sens à ma vie me permettent de me
sentir bien maintenant tout de suite aux
capus peur des chèques
y a plus peur d'eux qu'est ce que les
autres vont penser ce que je vais y
arriver il ya juste le fait est que si
je donne genre à cet arbre là je me sens
bien et ça m'amène sur une étude qui m'a
je vous laisse un petit peu de suspense
il étude qui maquille marc bué qui m'a
fait mal au ventre le jour j ai entendu
même fait tellement de bien
c'est l'étude qui a été menée par
brownie where i l'infirmière
australienne aller voir des personnes
dans le dernier jour de leur vie en leur
demandant comment il sentait par rapport
à leurs rêves et la majorité d'entre eux
avait des regrets des regrets non pas
pour ce qu'ils avaient fait des regrets
pour ce qu'il n'avait pas fait pour les
rêves auxquels il avait donné aucune
chance pour les risques qu'il n'avait
pas pris à la fin de notre vie tous ici
qui on a envie d'être
est ce qu'on a envie d'être la personne
qui sous prétexte qu'ils avaient peu de
chances d'y arriver à écrabouiller son
arbre ou est ce qu'on a envie d'être la
personne qui peut être n'a pas réussi
mais a au moins donné une chance à son
rêve
la personne qui à la fin de sa vie jeudi
se dit oui j'ai échoué mais capable de
regarder son enfant son fils sa fille et
dire j'ai au moins essayé je suis fier
de moi dans mes conférences souvent
jeudi que les enfants ont changé ma vie
et je me regarde bizarrement j'ai pas
d'enfant je dors dit voilà il n'y a pas
besoin d'avoir des enfants pour savoir
que mes enfants ils ont déjà changé ma
vie grecque le fait que je sache que je
veux des enfants c'est que
envie dès maintenant de décider de quel
papa ils vont avoir
je sais pas quand je vais les avoir mais
dans un an deux ans 5 ans 10 ans et j'ai
envie de pouvoir leur dire peu importe
que j'ai réussi mon nom j'ai donné une
chance à cet arbre là avancé vers ses
rêves c'est une façon de prendre soin de
soi c'est un acte d'amour envers soi au
début j'étais intéressé par comme je
vous le disais réussir plus tard mais
j'ai compris qu'à chaque fois que je
vois une personne s'occupait de ses
rêves elle devient vibrante elle devient
élue elle devient illuminé mais du coup
la différence que ça a fait pour moi
cette deuxième découverte c'est que
j'allais plus j'allais plus vers mes
rêves pour réussir j'allais leur mère
elle simplement parce qu en y allant
j'avais la sensation de m'occuper de moi
la sensation de faire quelque chose qui
était importante pour moi et la
possibilité de pouvoir être fier de moi
et du coup pour en revenir à cette arme
je pouvais m'occuper de cet arbre juste
parce que ça me donnerait et je
m'attendais pas à faire cette troisième
découverte le 17 novembre 2014
je reçois un sms sur cbs csms dit david
laroche m'inspire 2000 inspire son
public je vais réaliser un raid qui n'a
que 20 ans nouvelle vie va commencer
quand je lis je sais mais j'étais larmes
qui coulent sur mon visage
parce que ce sms c'est le cms de faber
avoir longtemps je voulais qu'elle
entendre les messages que je disais dans
les livres et puis un jour j'ai pris
cette troisième découverte quand tu
t'occupes de ton arme mais il ya des
gens qui te vois sans même que tu sache
qu'elle te vois et des fois elles se
disent si c'est possible pour lui si
c'est possible pour elle c'est peut-être
possible pour moi là c'est complètement
différent
tout à l'heure je vous parlais de
réaliser des rêves pour réaliser des
rêves ça pouvait faire pousser à
l'américaine dans un deuxième temps je
vous parlais de réaliser des rêves pour
devenir une nouvelle personne
mais là c'est autre chose là il s'agit
des gens qu'on aime
il s'agit de nos parents nos enfants nos
frères et soeurs il s'agit peut-être des
gens dans une salle il s'agit peut-être
d'un taxi avec lequel on peut parler et
ça donne je te trouve tellement plus de
puissance à cette première découverte on
a la chance comme dit gandhi avec cette
histoire que avec cette idée que ma vie
et mon message aura la chance en
s'occupant de notre arbre
deux peut-être voir quelqu'un s'occupe
du sien tous ici j'imagine et j'aimerais
avoir le point de pouvoir vous écoutez
j'ai dit que si vous êtes la personne
que vous êtes c'est grâce à quelqu'un
qui a su vous inspirez quelqu'un qui a
su vous dire sans même se rendre compte
des fois oui c'est possible pour toi oui
tu peux le faire ce peut être un
professeur un ami un parent un collègue
on a la chance aujourd'hui le pouvoir
aujourd'hui d'être cette personne pour
quelqu'un d'autre
non par voulant l'aider juste en voulant
céder juste en voulant donner une chance
à nos rêves parfois quand je discute
avec des personnes ce soit dans le taxi
dans le métro d'un porte ou n'importe où
dans le monde
je ressens de la frustration parce que
des fois quand je creuse je réalise
qu'il ya des rêve non réalisé des rêves
vont réaliser non pas parce que la
personne a échoué mais juste parce
qu'elle n'a même pas essayé
c'est pourquoi je ressens de la
frustration ressens de la frustration
parce que je connais par coeur ce que
c'est d'écraser ses rêves je sais ce
parce que c'est de me trouver des
excuses c'est par coeur ce que c'est on
est dans cette situation c'est la raison
pour laquelle si c'était la dernière
conférence de ma vie la dernière
occasion de l'ex privé auprès de
quelqu'un que j'aime
j'aimerais qu'ils entendent dans ses
tripes au fond de lui à l'intérieur de
lui oui c'est possible
quel rêve quel projet vous avez tendance
à écraser juste sous prétexte que c'est
peut-être impossible
jousse sous prétexte que personne ne l'a
fait juste sous prétexte que ça parait
dur notre première découverte c'est que
nous ne savons pas ce qui est possible
ou non
alors pourquoi pas agir comme si tout
est possible notre deuxième découverte
c'est finalement donner une chance à nos
rêves 7 vous rend vivant cette donne un
sens à nos vies que finalement le but
des rêves n'est pas de réussir un jour
plus tard mais de donner de l'énergie
ici et maintenant qu'à chaque fois qu'on
s'autorise à croire en ce rêve et d'y
aller c'est pas des buts qu'on atteint
des objectifs qu'on atteint mais c'est
une nouvelle personne pour devient
imaginons
qui on pourrait être dans un mois un an
10 ans 20 ans 30 ans et mon dernier jour
de notre vie si on donne une chance à
nos rêves le 3ème découverte c'était que
peut-être qu'en ayant le courage de s'en
occuper ya quelqu'un qui va nous voir et
se dire si c'est possible pour lui c'est
possible pour moi alors aujourd'hui on a
un choix le choix de donner une chance
un rêve encore possible peut-être qu'on
a écrasé un mais nous en reste et vous
attendre on a le choix d'y croire on a
le choix de nous en occuper dans le
choix d'agir non pas parce que c'est
facile ni même parce que c'est difficile
mais juste parce que cet arbre il
représente notre vie alors aujourd'hui
nous avons une chance à nos rêves juste
parce que c'est peut-être possible
merci à vous merci m